let's answer some of your questions I
really like all three questions this
week the first one is from Taylor Taylor
said David what do you think about
Osteopathy homeopathy and chiropractors
if you've ever heard me talk about
homeopathy before you probably know I
have very strong opinions about this I'm
gonna take each of these three
separately okay
Osteopathy Osteopathy well let's take
them together in a way first Osteopathy
homeopathy and chiropractors were all
medical ish worlds which when in the
early 20th century Western medicine
started going in the direction of being
evidence-based they sort of split off
right homeopathy and chiropractors
continued to be basically in the
netherworld of pseudoscience and non
science whereas osteopath ii actually
did go in the direction of mostly being
standard West Western evidence-based
medicine so today if you go to a school
where rather than becoming an MD you
become a do-right a Doctor of Osteopathy
your training is by and large very
similar to what you would get in a
medical school where you end up with an
MD as a medical doctor and then most
osteopaths would do a residency that is
identical to the one that someone that
goes to the standard medical school
would do so I know that there are some
disagreements about this but by and
large it's generally considered today
that dio's who have residency's that are
at respectable medical institutions are
more or less equally qualified to be
doctors as our MDS I know some people
will disagree with me on that but that
that's more or less what my research has
turned up homeopathy and chiropractors
are completely debunked pseudoscience
okay I mean homeopathy the concept is
that you dilute medications and I hate
to even use the term medications you
dilute substances
more and more and more with the idea
that the more deluded they are the more
powerful they become in terms of how
they impact your body
study after study has demonstrated that
homeopathy is not a treatment nor a cure
for any symptom nor condition . . i
recently met someone in my personal life
who loved that the green party used to
want federal funding for homeopathy and
is upset that now they don't because
quote homeopathy really works the
placebo effect is a very strong
phenomenon that we shouldn't discount
but homeopathy has been completely
debunked and then the entire idea of i
don't know if the word is chiropractic
or chiropractic of i don't want to call
it chiropractic arts but i also don't
want to call it
chiropractic science because i'm not
sure that's what it is it's sort of
based on the idea that the body can go
out of alignment and when this happens
there can be all sorts of repercussions
in terms of health that manifests in
different ways and by making adjustments
to the neck and spine and and different
areas you can put the body back into
alignment and eliminate all sorts of
medical conditions the problem is the
base of that that the body being quote
out of alignment can cause all sorts of
conditions it sort of sounds reasonable
like well you know different bodily
problems can manifest in different ways
in the same way that anxiety can
manifest as headaches or GI symptoms or
frequent urination or back pain or
whatever your body being out of
alignment could also cause all sorts of
conditions it hasn't actually been
demonstrated by science that the way in
which chiropractic work claims to
function is actually real so that's my
view on it my view on homeopathy and
chiropractors is really quite low
chiropractors also have drastically
higher rates of of malpractice lawsuits
because if you do the wrong thing in
terms of tweaking someone's neck or back
you could be paralyzed and people do
sometimes end up paralyzed and I know
people end up with negative
repercussions from so-called evidence
based Western medicine as well I totally
get that but this is at a very high rate
so that's my view
osteopath ii by and large has followed
evidence-based medicine into the 21st
century homeopathy and chiropractors i
would stay away from although and every
time I do this I get emails I know there
were people listening to me who will say
a chiropractic work and or homeopathy
did cure me of X Y or Z symptom or
condition unless we really have proper
scientific ideally double-blind studies
although in some of these cases
double-blind can be difficult anecdotes
are just anecdotes and they can't be
divorced from the impact of the placebo
effect which is both very significant in
medicine and also not to just be laughed
off right the placebo effect can be a
really good and useful thing and to that
extent I personally know many people
that have benefited from homeopathy
insofar as what was a need for something
that they wanted to feel like would be a
help to them I know a lot of people
won't like that answer